[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]
GEOFFREY NOER: Hi, everybody.
My name is Geoffrey
Noer, Product Manager
for Cloud Storage.
And here with me today is Mike
Yu, a senior staff software
engineer who will be joining
us for the second half
of the presentation.
This is all about cloud storage.
So this is our object store.
We realized, looking
at the session title
the last couple of days,
that we actually didn't have
the product name in the title.
So hopefully, all
of you are here
and care about object storage.
And we're going to be going
through best practices,
outlining some of our
most recent changes
to storage classes, and
also providing, hopefully,
some good guidance
on how to make
use of the product, especially
when it comes to performance.
So I'll start out.
I'll keep the marketing content
to a bare minimum, I promise.
Just a couple of slides to
introduce cloud storage.
But then focus in
on storage classes
and how best to apply
them, particularly
in the case of content serving.
Then we'll look
at the same thing
for the application
of storage classes
to compute and
analytics workloads.
And then finally,
get into some meat
on performance and scaling.
So let's dig in to
the introduction.
So for Google
Cloud, Cloud Storage
has been really one of the
core storage portfolio products
from the beginning.
And we've really cared
about making sure
that there's unified
experience across, no matter
how you use Cloud Storage.
So as you'll hear in the
storage classes section,
that's something
that we've continued
to stress with consistent
APIs and access.
Strongly consistent listings has
also been part of the product.
So it doesn't matter
when you list,
when you upload a product,
when you upload objects.
As soon as you list
them, you'll be
able to see the upload changes.
There aren't any consistency
challenges the way
you might see with other
cloud storage offerings
from other cloud providers.
Geo-redundancy-- so
all of Cloud Storage
is built around a global
approach to storage.
So we have regions, dual
regions, multi-regions.
And we make it very
easy to actually
have your storage distributed
with geo-redundancy.
And then finally,
of course, what
you would expect from
Cloud-- scalability,
no matter whether
you need gigabytes,
terabytes, petabytes,
or exabytes of storage.
So this is all
made possible based
on the enormous
investments that Google has
made in core infrastructure.
So this, of course, started long
before GCP actually existed.
This infrastructure was
actually put in place
to support Search,
YouTube, Gmail,
all the other big properties.
And then, once you have all
these subsea cable investments
and points of presence
globally and the ability
to do all of that
content distribution,
that's the ideal infrastructure
to build a public cloud
solution on top of.
And so what you'll see
is that we actually
have a great leverage of
all of that infrastructure
and continue to bring
onboard new regions.
Some of the most
recent ones include
Finland and the Nordics--
in Europe, we've
brought onboard.
So Hong Kong turned up
relatively recently.
Osaka has just been announced--
Salt Lake City.
So we have new regions
sprouting up everywhere,
all connected with very fast
networking infrastructure.
The three primary use cases that
you'll see for Cloud Storage
are content storage
and delivery.
And that leverages the
network that we just
talked about, right?
How do you bring your objects
and make them available
globally with high performance?
Computing and analytics and
machine learning, of course,
are taking a great
amount of interest.
And Google is seen
generally as being
one of the real
leaders in this area.
And then finally, we have a
lot of backup and archiving use
cases, as well.
So here you see just a
handful of household names
that use Cloud Storage
in each of these areas.
So let's dig into, now, some
of the most recent changes
in storage classes.
So storage classes
really dictate
how we place your
data, what regions,
and then, of course,
what the hotness
and coldness of the data,
how frequently you access it.
And up until today, actually,
we've had a mix of location
with hotness and coldness of
data in the storage class name.
So we've had this general
concept of storage class.
Multi-Regional and Regional,
were both the hottest classes.
But those referred
to the locations
where Multi-Regional
was geo-redundant
and Regional locked down the
data to a specific location.
And then we had Nearline and
Coldline for the archival use
cases.
But you could actually also
use those in a Regional
or Multi-Regional location.
So we felt like this was
actually a little bit
confusing to customers.
And so we're in the
middle of rolling out
changes that will make
this a little bit simpler.
So basically, what
we're looking to do
is we're going to be
separating out the location
type from the storage
class and only
using storage classes to
mean the data temperature,
the frequency of access.
So Standard is the most
frequently accessed.
Then, as the data
gets colder, you
go to Nearline and
then go to Coldline.
And it's a consistent
set of APIs,
no matter what storage
class you're using.
And then similarly,
on location type,
this really dictates the
amount of geo-redundancy
and where your data is
stored generally, right?
So if you're stored
in a region, you'll
know that all of your data
is in that specific region.
If you're in a
Multi-Region, you'll
be aligned to a continent.
So this will generally be, for
example, the United States,
the European Union, or
the Asia-Pacific region.
And then your data will be at
least in two places somewhere
in that continent.
And then dual
regions are the best
of both worlds, where you know
exactly where your data is.
It's in two specific regions.
And that allows you to co-locate
your compute with your storage.
And if you go up and down
within that stack from Standard
to Nearline to Coldline, the
geo-redundancy is preserved.
So in the past,
Nearline and Coldline
had regional
characteristics, even
if it was stored in a
multi-regional location.
So that's something that we've
improved as of last October,
that now the geo-redundancy
stays consistent
as you go up and down
within your buckets.
So here are examples of
regions, multi-regions,
and dual regions, going
back to that globe map.
So the big green
circles there are
illustrating the US and the
Asia-Pacific multi-regions.
There are two smaller ovals that
are dual regions, one in Europe
and one in North America,
where those are locked down
to two specific regions.
And then all of the
individual spots
there are individual regions
that we provide service in.
So why pick a particular
location type?
So regions offer the
lowest possible price point
and are specifically locked
around one data center.
So if you have jurisdictional
reasons, for example,
you want to make sure the data
stays in a particular country,
for example, especially
in Asia or in Europe,
that's one popular reason
to choose regional.
The other approach is
basically for co-location,
as you'll hear as we get into
some of the other specific use
cases.
Dual regions keeps
it locked down,
like I said, but with actually
two regions in the mix.
That gives you the higher
availability characteristics
without sacrificing the
knowledge that your data is
in specific locations.
But if you don't care
where your data is,
you just want it to be
very high availability
and you want it to be stored
in more than one region,
multi-region basically gives you
a price cut from dual regions.
And it gives Google
the freedom to store
your data in whatever data
centers within that region,
as makes sense.
So particularly for
content delivery,
we see a lot of use
of multi-regions.
So this is what happens
with data placement.
If you pick a region,
all of your objects
end up in that region.
So the green boxes
here under Region B
assume that you've selected
Region B as your region
for that particular bucket.
If you picked a multi-region
in the red color,
here you can see that
different objects--
they're still in at
least two regions,
but it's basically
randomized per object.
So you don't really know, for
any given object, what region
they're going to be in.
But you know that
they're geo-redundant.
Whereas here again,
for the dual region,
this dual region happens
to be Region B and C,
and so your objects are
always in those two locations.
So a big announcement
that we made this morning
is that we're actually adding
a new archive storage class.
So this is directly
aimed at tape replacement
needs and other very long
term storage requirements.
So if you're planning on
keeping your data around for 3,
5, 7, 10 years, don't
expect to access it,
would have considered
to put it on tape
before, this is
an ideal solution
for those sorts of needs.
So this really just adds another
tier to the storage classes.
And basically, you'll be
able to go from Standard
to Nearline to Coldline, and
now, to Archive and have,
really, a full suite of
storage class selections
for all of your needs.
And as you can
see, we're talking
about starting at a
price point of $0.12.
So this is a very
appealing price point.
But at the same time, this
is not a storage class
that's glacially slow.
It has the same performance
characteristics as all
the other storage classes.
So you don't need to
actually restore data.
So if you have 10
petabytes of storage
and that was stored
on tape, you might
be talking about weeks of
time to restore the data.
In this case, the data is right
there, immediately available
for your access.
You don't have to first
restore it to another bucket
under another storage class
to be able to access it.
It's available directly
out of the Archive class.
And we expect that,
even though this is data
that you don't want
to ever access,
if you do need to
access it, like there's
a regulatory reason that
you need to suddenly get
your data back and run
some analytics, here
you won't have to go
through a week long,
multi-week long period to
get access to your data.
And it's also stored with
very high durability.
One of the problems with tape
historically has been you
really have to write
it to tape, you
have to validate that it's
been correctly written.
And it's often the case that
when people go back to tapes,
that they find that their
data isn't there the way
they thought it is.
And tape libraries can
be very finicky devices.
So with Cloud Storage, and if
you select the Archive class,
it's stored with
the same 11 nines
durability that you've come to
expect from all of our storage
classes.
So we're very excited
about this announcement.
Archive will be available
later this year.
So stay tuned for availability.
And if you do choose
Archive, I want
to mention, in multi-regions
or in dual regions,
same level of geo-redundancy
applies as the other location
types would imply--
so very consistent
across-- consistent
APIs, consistent level
of geo-redundancy.
So what are the best practices
on selecting the storage
classes?
So hopefully you've already
selected a location type
that's appropriate for
the amount of availability
that your application
cares about.
But basically, it's a
combination of retention period
and access frequency.
So if you're going to
access data very frequently,
or if you're not going
to keep it very long,
then the Standard class
is going to give you
the best possible price point.
Whereas if you're going to
store it for, let's say,
10 years and never read
it, then clearly Archive
will be the best choice.
And in the middle fit
Nearline and Coldline.
So generally speaking,
if you're accessing it
less frequently than
once a year and storing
for more than 12 months,
that's where the new Archive
class fits in.
But we have a lot of use
of Nearline and Coldline,
especially for long
tail content archives
where the data is expected to
be read, maybe every month,
on average.
And that's where those
middle tiers make sense.
And then to unify
all of this, it's
great to have a consistent API.
But it's also useful to have
a policy driven mechanism
for down leveling the
tiers of your storage
as the data gets colder.
And so we provide that with
the Object Lifecycle Manager.
You can basically specify
based on the age of objects.
Usually, that
correlates very well
with the frequency of access.
So based on your data set,
if you understand that,
in this example--
after 30 days, your data really
should move off of Standard
and move into Nearline, then
after 90 days to Coldline,
and then after half
a year to Archive--
you can set up those policies.
And then your objects will
automatically tier down
to the appropriate level.
And of course,
because of the changes
that we made with the storage,
with the location types,
you don't have to worry about
losing durability or losing
geo-redundancy as
that tiering happens.
So if you choose a
Multi-Regional location,
for example, your data will
stay geo-redundant the whole way
down.
So that means consistent
availability characteristics
and consistent durability.
So now I want to talk a
little bit about application
of some of these storage
classes to workloads.
So I'll take you
through content serving.
And then pass the
baton over to Mike,
who will take the
presentation over from there.
So for content
serving, there actually
some interesting cases.
We have a lot of customers
that do direct serving.
But some use Cloud CDNs.
Some use Custom Front-ends,
but before serving the data.
And we also have
compelling use cases
with our independent
content delivery partners,
where they may be taking over
the last mile distribution.
And these all can mean some
slightly different things
for what storage class you
might ideally want to select.
So multi-regions see the
most use for direct serving.
And this is because if you're
serving to either the whole US
or even to the whole
globe, you don't really
care about where
the data is located.
You just want geo-redundancy
for the highest availability,
and you want it to be taking
advantage of all of the caching
that Google makes available.
So we have cache control
headers that allow you to state,
to control that caching.
But generally speaking, as
soon as an object has already
been read in a particular
point of presence,
it will be cached there
and very low latency
for subsequent accesses.
So we do encourage you to take
advantage of the cache control
headers for direct serving.
To optimize direct
serving further,
you can take advantage
of our Cloud CDN product.
And what this allows you
to do is basically avoid
a lot of the more
expensive egress pricing
in the cases of cache hits.
And the other part
of what this does
is it allows you to
get HTTPS in custom
domains, some flexibility
on the URL side.
But fundamentally, it just
takes the caching capability
that's already there
in the basic product
and gives you a little
bit more capability
and some opportunity
for some cost
savings on the egress side.
So that's very
commonly used as part
of the direct serving model.
So so far, that's pretty much
all a multi-regional use case.
Custom Front-ends is where
multi-regions may no longer
make as much sense.
So this is where you
want to actually put
VMs in front of your content
serving, because you're
going to manipulate
the data in some way
before it gets sent
out to your customers.
And in that case,
the overall latency
from storage to your
customers access
is both the latency from
storage and then the latency
from the VM.
And so if you want to
minimize the overall latency,
it's important to
actually co-locate
the storage with the VMs
that are accessing it.
So here, you want to either
use a region or a dual region
to store the data
ideally, so that you'll
know that the storage is local
to the region in which it's
being accessed by
your front-ends.
If you want geo-redundancy,
use a dual region.
And then you can have your
VMs in both of the regions.
If it's very low
performance, you may still
get away with multi-regions.
So it's not a hard
and fast rule.
But generally speaking,
you might be better off
with regions and dual regions.
And then you can also use
independent content delivery
networks.
Some of our partners are
shown here on this slide.
It may be that they have
particular APIs, feature sets
that are particularly
well-aligned to the market
that the content
is being served to.
It may be that the
particular pops that they
have are in better alignment
or maybe the egress pricing
offers some advantages.
It depends on the scenario.
But we work very closely
with these partners,
and it's a great alternative
if, for some reason,
the direct serving or our own
CDN capabilities fall short.
So here you would want to use
regional or dual regions, again
for the same reason.
Typically, there
will be something
that's called an origin shield
that's placed between Google
and that CDN partner.
And what the origin shield
does is it basically
ensures that the cache filling
is going to that origin shield
directly from Google.
And it prevents a ton of access
from going back and hitting
Google at the same time.
So it ends up being the
intermediary between Google
and the CDN partner.
So if you have that origin
shield layer co-located
as closely as possible
with the storage,
again, you help with
the overall latency.
So at this point I'd
like to pass the baton
to Mike Yu, who will take
you through the next section.
MIKE YU: Right.
Thanks, Geoff.
OK.
So we're going to quickly go
through storage class selection
and location type selection
for computing and analytics.
And then I'll talk a little bit
about some general performance
and scaling tips.
So one of the things I think is
a little bit interesting here
is that in your computing
analytics pipelines,
there's actually
several types of data.
And your choice of location type
depends on the type of data.
So first of all, you
have source data.
This is data that's
typically persistent
and you need to load up when
you start up your pipeline.
And here, what's
really important
is very high throughput.
So you want co-location between
your workers and your data.
So region and dual
region make sense.
The second type is
intermediate data.
And here, this one is a
little bit interesting.
This is data that's produced
by one stage of your pipeline
and consumed by the next.
And it doesn't actually always
make sense to use GCS here.
We've actually found a lot
of users who need higher
throughput, lower latency.
And this data is
very short-lived.
And so sometimes using something
like local SSD makes sense.
There are also sometimes
specialized services,
like a shuffle service, that you
can get a higher performance.
The third type of data is what
I call side inputs and staging
data.
So this is data that's
typically read once per worker.
It's loaded all up together.
But then after that,
it's never read again.
And here, the type of
location doesn't really
matter that much.
And the reason why
is that GCS ends up
doing a lot of caching
behind the scenes.
And so you're fetching the
same data over and over.
So even if it's
remote the first time,
subsequent times are
typically nice and fast.
And then finally,
there's final outputs.
What does your pipeline
actually produce?
And here, the location
type and source class
really depends on
what you're going
to do with the final output.
So if you're producing, say,
process images that you're
going to serve out
to internet users,
you'd probably want to
use the advice that Geoff
gave on content serving and
choose a storage class based
off of that.
If instead, this is
going to be data that's
going to be fed into
another pipeline,
then it would end up acting
like source data again.
And you would want to use
regional or dual regional.
I wanted to give a quick blurb.
Because we've been
seeing a lot of interest
in using-- moving Hadoop
workloads to the Cloud.
And so I wanted to
give a shout out
to our Cloud DataProc service,
which is a managed Hadoop
service.
It lets you bring up
clusters very, very quickly.
And we also have
a connector that
allows you to access your source
data and your final outputs
directly from GCS without having
to load it first into HFS.
So you can save a bit of
time by skipping that step.
There are a couple of gotchas.
Object storage is
not a file system.
So we don't have
directory semantics today.
So you're going to want to
work around those and eliminate
your dependency on atomic
directory operations.
So for example, one
common pattern that we see
is that you might
write data temporarily
into a temporary directory.
And then when your
data set is complete,
you'll rename it to
a final directory.
And an alternate approach is
to go ahead and write that
into the final directory.
And when your data
set is complete,
write a sentinel file that says,
hey, I'm done with the data.
I'll talk a little bit
in a bit on performance.
But you're going to see
that object storage is
going to have higher latency
overall compared to HFS.
And so you're going to want
to favor parallelization
to get around that.
And then finally, like
I already mentioned,
you may want to use local
SSD for temporary data.
OK.
So let's now talk about
some performance and scaling
tips, which I think are really
applicable across multiple use
cases.
So I think the first
thing to understand
is the general performance
characteristics
of object storage.
And the TLDR is that
latency for small objects
is relatively high.
So at 95th percentile,
you might expect, like,
a one byte read to take about
100 milliseconds, give or take.
It depends a bit on the
hotness of the object,
but around 100 milliseconds,
and similarly for writes.
On the flipside, I think where
our strengths are, of course,
horizontal scalability and
then single stream throughput.
So with a object
that's large enough,
you should be able to get
about 800 megabits or about
100 megabytes per second.
And for writes, you can get
about 400 megabits per second.
So what this means
is that you're
going to really want to try
to favor larger object sizes.
If you have options in terms
of how to pack your data,
don't shard them unnecessarily.
Try to keep the objects
relatively large.
Because you can see on
the graph on the right,
you're not really able to take
advantage of the single stream
throughput until you get
to larger object sizes.
Similarly, even if you are
able to pack all your data
into larger objects, if
you have structure data,
you may have internal
segments or pages.
And if you can, you
want to tune those
to be a little bit larger.
We recommend about
two megabytes.
If you can go larger,
it's even better.
But it's sort of a trade
off between how much you
read at once and how
much effort is wasted,
depending on your query.
And then, like I mentioned
earlier, sometimes you
can't create larger objects.
You have no choice,
and that's OK.
Just make sure you
parallelize so that you
work around the inherent
latency that's in the service
and that you can increase
your throughput that way.
So next, let's talk a little
bit about writing objects
and how to get the best
performance out of writes.
There's actually three
high level strategies
you can use for writes.
The simplest one is just
a non-resumable upload.
You use your single request.
You upload your entire object.
The second strategy is to do
what we call resumable upload.
So we have a protocol where
you first send a request
to initiate a new
resumable upload session,
and you get back a
unique session ID.
And then you issue
a second request
where you upload your data.
And hopefully that succeeds.
But if it fails,
what you can end up
doing is you can query
the server and say,
hey, what was the last offset
that you were successfully
able to commit?
And once you have
that offset, you
can then issue another
upload request and only
upload the bytes that the
server hasn't received.
The third approach
is parallel upload.
So you can split your
object into parts,
you can upload them, and
then you can do a compose.
The compose operation is
a metadata only operation,
so it's constant time.
It doesn't rewrite
any of the bytes.
And if you have your
entire object up front,
you can, of course, split it
upfront and upload those parts.
You can get the sharding
done right away.
If you're doing a
streaming approach
and you don't know what
the final object size is,
you can iteratively
chunk your buffer, upload
that in chunks,
compose, and then
do it again for the next
set of bytes in your buffer.
So obviously, you want to
use non-resumable uploads
by default. But I think
what's not really always
clear is how high of a bar you
want to use before you switch
over to resumable upload.
Resumable uploads have
several disadvantages.
One of the big ones
is that they require
a minimum of two requests.
And if you imagine that that
first request takes something
on the order of, say,
100 milliseconds, that
means for small objects,
that 100 milliseconds
is a large part of the
overall upload time.
So it's a large
amount of overhead.
So the general rule
of thumb I like to use
is take your expected
throughput, multiply it
by about 30 seconds, and
that's a reasonable cutoff
time for the object size
before you want to switch over
to resumable uploads.
What that means is
that you're going
to lose, at most, 30 seconds of
effort if something goes wrong.
And things go wrong
very rarely usually.
It also means that, as you
hit that 30 second threshold,
the amount of overhead that
that first request adds
is relatively small,
less than half a percent.
And so to give you
some concrete numbers,
if you have clients
that are using,
say, cable, cable
modem access, and they
have a four megabit per
second upload speed,
then the cutoff is going
to be about 15 megabytes.
Similarly, if you have a
VM that's on our network,
you're getting the full
400 megabits per second,
you shouldn't really be even
considering resumable uploads
till about over a gig or so.
So it's fairly large
objects before you really
want to care about this.
And then finally, if resumable
uploads have a high bar,
I would say parallel uploads
have an even higher bar.
You really only want-- there's
a lot of additional complexity
that you add with this.
So it's not something
you want do lightly.
You should really only do this
if you are uploading from a VM
and you really need greater
than 400 megabits per second.
That typically means you're
talking very, very large object
sizes, right, tens
of gigabytes or more.
There is one other
use case, which
is that certain connections
have relatively high bandwidth,
but a relatively high delay.
And due to the way GCP
works, you sometimes
are not able to fill your pipe.
In those cases, sometimes
having multiple connections
is beneficial.
So next, I want to
talk about retries.
It sounds a little bit dry, but
it actually has a big impact
on both the reliability
and the performance
that you're going to get.
So right here, I have a
pretty typical retry strategy.
It's exponential back off.
We have a loop.
We make a call.
There's a deadline.
If there's a retriable error,
we back off exponentially,
and we give up after a
fixed number of attempts.
So there's, I think, two
tricky things to consider here.
So first of all, right
now with every attempt,
we're reissuing
the same request.
And so there's a
question of, is that
the right strategy for
getting the best reliability?
The second question is,
we have this deadline.
So what's the right deadline?
If you do it too
short or too long,
that has impact on
performance or reliability.
So let's look into
those one by one.
So first of all, I think
the key thing with retries
is you really want to be
failing over if at all possible.
So this is sort of
a simplified view
of what Cloud storage might look
like in this implementation.
We have a set of front-ends.
They're running on multiple
servers and they're stateless,
so you can really hit
any of those servers.
Now we have a set
of metadata servers,
and those are stateful.
And so for any given
object, you need
to go to a specific
subset of those servers.
And similarly, we
have data servers.
And you can only use
a specific subset.
So those are
represented in blue.
So imagine a user makes a
request for a specific object.
It hits one of the front-ends.
It hits one of the
metadata servers.
It hits one of the data servers.
And something goes wrong.
Well, if the error happens at
the metadata or data level,
then Cloud storage
is going to take
care of retrying automatically.
And it's going to failover
to the alternate replica.
So this should all
happen under the hoods.
So that's great, because
it means we're not retrying
the same unhealthy node, right?
The problem is what happens
if the front-end itself
is unhealthy.
A naive retry
strategy would end up
reusing the same TCP connection
or the same HTTP connection,
and you'll end up hitting
the same unhealthy front-end.
So it's pretty important
that when you do your retry,
make sure you're actually
opening up a new connection.
Our load balancing will
typically send that
to a different server.
And you're unlikely-- and that
will cause proper failover.
So let's also talk
about deadlines now.
I mentioned that if it's
too short or too long,
there's repercussions.
So if you're setting that
deadline that's too short,
the biggest problem is that
you might be prematurely
canceling or failing
a request that
could have succeeded if you
were just willing to wait
a little bit longer.
And that ends up driving up
your error rate artificially.
It ends up wasting work, right?
Similarly, if you set a
deadline that's too long,
the problem is that you
may sit around waiting
too long for a request that's
never going to succeed.
And if you had just
retried a little earlier,
you could have really
cut down that latency.
So what do you do?
What we recommend
doing is a technique
called hedged requests.
The problem with the
previous algorithm
is that each attempt
had to run individually.
They couldn't run in parallel.
So if you instead issue your
retries in parallel, what that
allows you to do is
each individual attempt
can have a long
deadline so that we
wait for a long enough time in
case the whole service is slow.
And at the same time,
you can shorten the delay
before issuing that second
request so that you can really
cut down on your tail agency.
So I can walk through this
in a little bit more detail
to hopefully make it more clear.
So imagine you issue
your initial attempt.
And it's taking a little
while to come back.
In fact, it's a
little beyond normal.
One good way to
implement this is
to track what your
typical P95 latency
is, say over the
last minute or two.
And so you wait, and you
haven't yet received a response
after hitting your P95 latency.
So what you can go ahead
and do is issue that retry,
that second attempt.
But don't cancel the first one.
Let it keep going, right?
And if this is a scenario where
that first attempt happened
to hit a slow node and
it's just taken a while
and the second attempt
fails over properly,
then you'd expect
that second attempt
to succeed pretty quickly.
And so you've really cut down
your latency quite a bit.
If, on the other hand, let's
suppose this first request
was taking a long
time, not because you
hit a by a single slow
node, but maybe the service
is having issues overall.
Well, because you've
set a long deadline
for each of these requests, you
didn't cancel that first one.
And so that allows that
first request to succeed.
It will be, of course, slow.
But at least you're not
wasting work or throwing away,
causing errors prematurely.
So that's head requests.
And I wanted to throw
out two other things
that I think are pretty
important, especially
if you do use head requests.
I think the first one
is to make sure to limit
your retry volume.
And of course, this helps
us, the service, from getting
slammed when things
are unhealthy.
But it also helps your client.
And if you noticed in the
previous hedged request slides,
I suggested you waiting
for the P95 latency
before issuing
the head requests.
That means in steady
state, you're only
issuing about 5% extra traffic.
But the problem is that
latency can temporarily spike.
If it temporarily
spikes, then you
could be issuing up
to 100% extra traffic.
And so limiting
your retry volume
to a smaller subset, say 10%,
is generally a good practice.
The other thing to be
careful about with retries
is making sure you have
idempotent sequences.
This is something that we've
seen a few different users
forget about.
And it can cause serious
problems, like data loss.
So I thought it was worth
going into that really quickly
to explore that.
So a non-idempotent sequence is
a sequence of operations where,
if you repeat the entire
sequence or a subsequence--
it's idempotent if you always
end up with the same state.
It's non-idempotent if
it's possible to end up
in a different state.
So here's an example of a
non-idempotent sequence.
Imagine we create
an Object X and that
creates Generation Number 1.
Then we issue a delete
operation, which deletes it.
And then we follow
that up by creating
a new version of that object.
So that's Generation Number 2.
So this shows what happens
in that sort of normal case
where no errors occur.
So here's an example of what
can happen if an error occurs
and you issue a retry.
So imagine that the
initial create succeeds.
Your initial delete
request takes a long time,
and so you time out.
And when you time out,
you issue that retry,
and that retry succeeds.
So now you've deleted
Generation Number 1.
You then go ahead and
create the object again.
And you've created
Generation Number 2.
And the problem is, is that
very first delete attempt,
even though you timed it
out on the client side,
it was actually stuck
in one of the buffers
in our server, one of
the queues in our server.
And so it does end up
getting applied and ends up
deleting the Generation 2
object that you just created.
So this is a data loss scenario.
So you really want to make
sure that your sequences are
idempotent to avoid
this type of problem.
One way of doing that
is to use preconditions.
So in this example, we
can really make sure.
Rather than saying
delete Object X,
we can say delete Object
X Generation 1 only.
And that ensures that that dark
request that came in afterwards
or that finished
afterwards gets canceled.
Because it is no longer relevant
to the current generation
of the object, which
is Generation 2.
There are other
ways of doing this.
Another common
technique for doing this
is to simply never overwrite
objects with new content.
Right?
So you can write once.
And if you ever have
to rewrite, it's
always rewriting
the same content.
OK.
Finally, I wanted
to end and talk
a little bit about
scaling and hotspotting.
And generally speaking,
scaling is something
that Cloud Storage
does pretty well.
You don't typically have
to worry about your data
size or the object count.
We just scale horizontally,
usually without worry.
But there is one case that
we have seen a lot of folks
get tripped up on.
And that is localized
hotspotting,
which can also result in
scaling bottlenecks, as well.
And so I wanted to give a little
bit of intuition and background
for what's happening under the
hoods and then, some advice
on it on how to
work around this.
So Cloud Storage uses a
scaling or sharding strategy
called range-based sharding.
And so what that means
is we, of course,
store your objects
on multiple servers.
And the way we assign
objects to servers
is we split up your object
namespace into ranges.
So in this example,
an object starting
with C would go into that
first shard and an object
starting with M would go
into the second shard.
And we chose this strategy for a
very specific purpose, which is
to provide consistent listing.
So imagine a user issues a
request to list every object
starting with t/.
In order to fill this
request, it's pretty simple.
The request needs to get
routed to a single shard,
this S shard, and that shard
is sufficient to service
the entire request.
We know that there are no
objects starting with t
in any of the other shards.
So let's look at an
alternative approach
to what we could have done.
The alternate approach
is to do something
like hash-based sharding,
where you take the object name,
you hash it, and
then you assign it
to one of the shards
based off of the hash.
And that really distributes
the objects all over the place.
So this same listing
operation now, what happens?
In order to service
a request, you
have to look at every
single shard, right?
Because you don't know where
the t/ objects are going to be.
And what happens
if a shard is slow?
You have to wait for it.
So as the number of
shards increases,
you're going to hit
that tail latency.
Your overall listing
latency is going to go up.
Perhaps even worse, what happens
if one of the shards fails?
Then you're stuck with
a sort of poor choice.
You can either return
incomplete results
or you can fail the
overall request.
And again, as the
number of shards
increases, assuming you're
failing the overall request,
your chance of
success goes way down.
So because of this,
hash-based sharding really
doesn't scale well when
you're trying to provide
strongly consistent listing.
And so we've gone with
range-based sharding.
So of course, one of
your shards can get hot.
And we do auto scale,
and we detect that,
and we split those
shards in half or more
to try to distribute load.
And I wanted to give a feel
for when this becomes an issue.
You should expect about 1,000
object writes per second
and about 5,000
reads per second.
That's probably a
little bit conservative.
But that's roughly what you
can expect for any given shard.
And then, when the
shard gets hot,
we try to split ahead of time
so that you don't notice things.
But you can expect a
delay of about 20 minutes
if you are slamming
a particular shard.
That's also, again, probably
a little bit conservative.
But I think it's
good to keep in mind,
because this is about
when you're going to run
into these type of problems.
And in order for
this to work well,
I think the key thing
is to make sure you're
distributing your load evenly.
If you have a nice,
consistent, even load,
then we can really detect
shards getting hot.
And we can split them well ahead
of that becoming a problem.
So there is one common pattern
that essentially trips up
a lot of uses.
And that's sequential access.
And let's go through
why this is problematic.
So by sequential access,
I mean reading or writing
objects in order of their name,
right, in lexicographic order.
And in this example, we have g,
h, i, j, k, so pretty simple.
And you can see that these
accesses are distributed
across two range-based shards.
But the biggest problem
here is that, even
though overall the accesses are
distributed across those two
shards, if you take a look
at any particular time range,
it's always lasering
one shard at a time.
So you don't actually get
the scaling properties
of having two different shards.
You're really bound by the
limit of a single shard.
So that's what we
mean by hotspotting.
You're really lasering
this one shard.
A potential way around this is
to go ahead and say, OK, well,
let's split these shards up
into smaller ranges, right?
And this definitely does
help spread the load.
But it causes fragmentation.
And fragmentation
is a problem, again,
because of consistent listing.
Previously, with a
low fragmentation,
the list operation can hit
a relatively few number
of shards.
With high fragmentation, you
end up having to hit many shards
and you start running
into the same tail
latency and
availability problems
that you would get with
hash-based sharding.
So I wanted to go
through this because this
is sort of a fundamental trade
off that you have to make,
and it's pretty difficult
to get around this.
So here are some
common naming patterns
that we see that cause this
type of sequential access.
So one of them is
using year, month, day.
You see this a lot with
writing logs, for example.
You also see things like
having order numbers or user
IDs that are sequential, just
counting up monotonically.
And then, similarly, we
also see use of timestamps.
So these are three
common patterns
that we see that
can cause problems.
There are a couple
of ways you can work
around this if you need to.
And again, I want
to re-emphasize,
it really only becomes
a problem after 1,000
writes per second or
5,000 reads per second.
So oftentimes this
isn't an issue.
One of the things
you can do is--
I'm just going to call
it, like, manually
partitioning your prefixes.
So in this example, we
pulled the log type upfront.
And that means that if I'm
processing a single day
across multiple log
types, I'm going
to end up hitting
multiple prefixes at once,
and then I'm going
to get a fixed
multiplication of the sharding.
The second approach is to
just don't use sequential IDs
if you don't have to.
So for order numbers,
if you don't really
need that count of
the number of orders,
for example, just use
a uuid and that'll
spread the load more evenly.
The third approach
is you can end up
taking a hash of
your object name
and putting that
into your prefix.
And so in this
particular example,
I didn't hash the entire name.
But I hashed timestamp,
and I put that up front.
And this gives you really
good, even load balancing.
The big drawback is that you
no longer get in order listing.
So again, this only
works if you don't really
need to list in order.
And finally, there
is an alternative
that you can do that's
a little bit in between.
You can hash, and then map it
to a fixed number of shards.
And what this ends
up allowing you to do
is it allows you to preserve
the in order listing
by issuing 10 listing operations
in parallel, one to each shard,
and merging the results.
So it's extra work.
But if in order listing is
absolutely something you need,
and you also need to get
around the scaling limitations,
this is an approach
that you can take.
Finally, I wanted to mention--
all the previous alternatives
I mentioned were around naming.
You don't always have to
actually change a name.
In the case of bulk
operations, you
can simply make sure that
your access is spread evenly
and randomly.
So for example, if I'm
running a batch job
across my entire corpus, I
could have the different workers
process different
directories simultaneously
and that would cause
more even load.
You can also randomly choose
which objects to process,
and that will distribute
the load a little bit more
evenly, as well.
So with that, hopefully
you found it useful.
That's the main tips that
we wanted to provide today.
We didn't cover a
lot of other areas.
I know there's a lot
of tips in security.
There's a lot of
tips around archival.
So I wanted to
give a quick plug.
We have 10 other storage
talks that are ongoing.
The ones in blue, these are
ones that haven't been held yet.
So if you want to catch
them live and they're
interesting to you, I'd
encourage you to do that.
The ones that
aren't highlighted,
they've already happened.
But they should be on
YouTube pretty soon.
And so there's good
tips on, for example,
seeing how Twitter is
migrating their workload to us
for a very high intensity
computer use case
and also how to do things like
transferring your data in.
Hopefully everyone
found that useful.
Geoff and I are going
to hang out afterwards.
And we're happy to answer
questions that you might have.
So thank you.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC PLAYING]